Bill Burr has performed stand-up comedy
in some of the coolest venues on Earth
from under the stars at Red Rock to
selling out Fenway Park in fact Bill
Burr is the only comedian ever to
perform at Fenway and last week bill
made history again taking the stand-up
comedy virginity of another legendary
venue the Odin of hirdois in Athens
Greece was built
1862 years ago in the year 161 A.D
stand-up comedy has been done in a lot
of cool places over the last few years
but an ancient Roman Amphitheater has to
be at the top of the list it might be a
while until Bill Burr is able to find a
venue to Top This one eventually he's
gonna have to start looking into being
the first comedian to perform in space
because